so it's nice to see you bring back the
way that I've used an amazing job as
Cedric but as angry kick-ass right it's
so great that footage in that trailer is
a phenomenal so it's been fun it's been
fun right you feel if you feel like
you're you're feel like you're you again
you know yeah it's um it was it's great
you know being ranked in by version but
you know there's something about getting
back yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
really hadn't had a nice arc in the
sentence and we talked about this before
he kind of went from glands really I
mean this is kind of a crappy thing to
say but the apocalypse kind of made of a
man in a weird sort of way would you
agree with it I think I think everyone
in this apocalypse has gotten their
potential completely unlocked I think
Glenn was someone maybe back at home he
wouldn't have been the person that he is
dealing pizzas but now you know he has
love he has friendship his family and
his name's to protect so yeah he's
learned a lot and how are you how do you
how could you sort of describe where his
mental says that at the end of last
season where it's fine that you don't
like him and finally he finally came
together they didn't really have a ton
of time I mean so much was like hey
choo-choo-choo-choo so how do you where
do you think he feels Center anything is
whole again you know I think for him you
know last season he overcame an
incredibly impossible paths to find the
people that you lost and he held out
hope and it got to that place and so
moving forward you know they find
themselves in very in a very dire
situation but I think he still holds out
hope he still has that fight in him and
you know I think he's carrying on the
legacies of all people as well as all of
us are do you think these characters
is do you think they could never never
ever find some settle down at some point
plan a normal life or anything they're
just kind of broken forever
oh I feel like I feel like even if we
cured the orange juice it would still be
a lot of bad guys out there I think we
can only agree that once this happens in
the well nobody's going to be the same
office a baby
I don't know out of school statue as V
shaped man so how did you get like when
you read the comics did you picture
yourself like this guy interesting I was
obviously don't look like that don't
know too many people that they're dead
in real life that's comic book Abraham
so I just I said I was gonna meet him
somewhere in the mill do my end to get
to where I could and you know it's all
about that too mostly so he's a badass
how did it feel
I mean these fans like coming into you
know this sort of pre-existing family in
the cast and everyone's everyone's been
there for a while and you're the new guy
did you feel right away a late night
click and I fit in normally these guys
are fantastic I mean this is this is
obviously arguably the largest show in
the world and you come into it you know
sort of go to sailing of a season it's
it's it's interesting yeah you know they
may they all welcome me it's a nice
story this year you know coming in fresh
you know I described as you know the
first season was sort of
to somebody's house and you know you
sort of like you did a safe on the couch
and this year they built your room I
feel very very welcomed by everyone and
I'm just excited to see all this and you
guys are holy crap there's a lot I don't
know you can see yourself come on I'm
going to close up your hair is like
electric orange I have no idea what your
time Michelle had such an amazing season
this past season and haven't seen so
many different signs ever shown what is
more challenging for you when you get
all torn up physically or is it like
when you get torn up emotionally like
what what's more challenging for you as
a former you I really actually really
loved both sides of her and I love this
character promise in each both sides
like I've got to go there for her in
whichever direction she needs me to and
initially I was really afraid of how
physical she was so she's definitely
more agile than me so I had to catch up
and I consistently have to catch up with
what she's capable of but actually
before she was able to start working
through her own old wounds it was
emotional stuff that was under the
surface that I had to stay connected to
that wasn't actually proved to be really
challenging because those really dark
hard stuff that she was holding onto so
tightly so it actually that was actually
very challenging and then now she's kind
of a different place which is really
somewhat easier in some ways to play but
also challenging because she's
than that that can be hard for her
because she's she's enjoy being tough
but she knows it's not all she is so
they both actually been really
really enjoyable to do as a former but
both very challenging and every search
should pick up there like a gig you
gotta like pull that off this week in
terms of the physical needs so she's
keeps me on my toes
which is great that's what I have
something for first of all the board
[Applause]
honey trying to talk about seeing a
character come out of their shell and
dominate you I mean Carol this past
season was she's really become a like
she's really become a true leader and
done stuff that I don't know any of the
characters have been able to do so what
do you how do you feel about Carol right
now and what are your thoughts going
into season five about what she's
prepared to do it's coming to the world
the way it is and this is what you have
to do now that she's come to a place of
courage to be able to do those tough
things I don't know she's she's very
good pathetic character but how does she
keep has she keep grounded like how do
you how does the Lizzie thing happen and
then she's like all right let's move
like hot she stay centered
because interest center she feels
justified and it comes from a place of
caring I think if it weren't for that in
your mind what was happening with
Tyreese in that moment well you know
what hope you say hope and heart I'm
told demonstrated self in this world you
know if it could be don't if you don't
have the heart can't have a hope you
know so when he sees he said you know
there was no time really then he lost
sight of her humanity though if he
really trapped the way we went through
we had you know it's a horrific
experience of a shared experience and uh
complicit agreement to have to take out
listen you know so that that's a lot of
I mean I saw her so I didn't see this
villain I I saw someone who was
incredibly brave and an incredibly harsh
world so that's why I was able to to
give her also these either this is
there's a little community I mean if
we're gonna have hope then we gotta
believe we're going to be
sustained committee and we've got to we
got to build from Subway you know so
destroying that community dis lesson
zone that much more more so you know
it's a twisted world but thanks looks
like now you know doesn't look warm and
fuzzy like maybe in the real world right
but hey that's that's what it is yeah so
it's very nice to see you in the trailer
it's nice that that is out there
somewhere so what can you tell us about
where do you think she's at up to the
point that we the last time you see her
yeah I can't tell you really anything
about um about where she is next season
but I can't tell you that she's gotten a
lot stronger you know into five and um
kind enough to use everything she's got
nice enormous old form estrogen
you can't say a word nor do like did you
have any inkling at the beginning of
season 1 that this was the emotional
journey then Tara would take no I've no
idea but it kind of blows me away how it
keeps going forward how everyone
everybody on this kind of that none of
these customers are the same people in
season one not even close is how it's
written
you constantly evolve and I think I'm
just so beat up right now and like
Lauren was saying it's it's probably
easier to be emotional when you're so
physically beat up but this is a job
that we love on through you you never
know where things are gonna go I'm
curious to see where they go now most
being a care for evolution I wanna ask
Andy where do you think which Cherokee
thinks all the most since season one
well yeah I mean as no one saying all of
us about this incredible journey but
that is one business really young
changed more than anybody else I mean
when I first met him he was yeah he's
very the size of his action figure
little Ewok
[Music]
and I was it's easy soup I was able to
carry him I'm able my background doing
it and season five I'm hoping that he
will carry me respected being on the
show would attach you to pudding for the
rest of your life you saw the picture of
yourself you saw that you were a young
young lad but this series started what
what is it felt like to grow up on this
show
[Music]
how do you use your voice
[Applause]
growing up on this show has been it's
been so much fun and it's gossip I I had
the most amazing actors work with that
mentors here to work with and it's been
awesome
it's so much fun I am growing up on the
show you know the Florida question so
make sure we have enough time for fan
questions so know you guys waited
[Applause]
[Music]
honey what's your question what do you
see in yourself and then
[Applause]
there's a whole bunch of me in there a
little bunches there let me I mean when
I say the USA trust my friends it takes
a long time for me to trust in this well
[Music]
yeah the same cloth I think different
parts of the world now I'm so excited to
see bug lady so excited to see what this
is it this is the
everyone together with something to do
your pickle bookmark how many months you
make since last time ago mm Jesus well
that's amazing
do you have some for us later yes I do
what is your question for the panel my
question ELISA in the scene where you're
talking with Tyrese about confessing to
him do you think that carol was really
after losing the girls that she's so
desperately trying to say that she was
looking before suicide by Tyrese and
that she was shocked when he actually
forgave her
but maybe bring him down with a serious
[Music]
[Applause]
I think she was ready to accept the
faith that he chose for her and the
important thing in that scene for her
was to allow him the choice to let him
experience what having that choice feels
like but she never expected that he
would forgive her sure